[Music]
testosterone has a reputation
a bad reputation
only a jerk would act like that complete
idiot
it is often associated violence range
and aggression but it's also associated
with sex and power the amount of
testosterone in your body may be
equivalent to a pinch of sugar in an
Olympic swimming pool and it has these
profound effects to understand how it
works in humans scientists are looking
at the beginning of life
when human life begins all fetuses look
female both males and females are
exposed to testosterone in the womb boys
produce significantly more
[Music]
love is peak at around four months the
amount of testosterone that male and
female fetuses are exposed to at this
critical point affects how the body and
brain are built less testosterone can
result in better verbal skills more
testosterone can be to better visual
spatial skills like this mental rotation
test and parallel parking the amount of
testosterone that an individual was
exposed to in utero can be gauged in
some surprising ways according to some
studies it shows up in the hands
specifically the relationship in length
between the pointer and ring fingers
it's called the two d4e ratio a longer
pointer finger compared with the length
of the ring finger means lower
testosterone exposure in the world a
pointer fingers shorter than the ring
finger indicates a high dose was
received in utero
having a longer ring finger has been
correlated with high sperm count
assertiveness in women and athletic
ability if a glance at someone's hand
can reveal mental ability personality
traits or athletic skill could this
prejudice a potential employer opponent
or mate could such a simple method be
reliable cd40 research is controversial
but it does appear the testosterone is
determining a lot about who we are
before we are even born